in this video we're going to cover some
substitution and elimination practice
problems so I can take you through my
thought process when I look at these
problems and hopefully help you when
you're having to approach them on your
own remember there are four main factors
that we need to consider to figure out
what's going on in these mechanisms the
most important is substrate structure
which all abbreviate as s when I'm
talking about it we also need to
consider the leaving group is there a
good-enough leaving group on the
molecule for substitution or elimination
to even occur will abbreviate that LG if
you watched my 10 minute substitution
elimination summary video you might
recall that the nucleophile was really
important in determining reaction
mechanisms will abbreviate that nuke
finally there may be solvent effects
that we need to consider since we
already used s here we'll use v for
solvent
okay let's tackle our first problem
together here we're treating this
bromide with sodium acetate and acetic
acid let's consider the leaving group
first the leaving group is a halogen
with the exception of fluorine halogens
are among the best leaving groups so we
have a great leaving group and we know
substitution and elimination can occur
next let's consider the substrate
structure the most important factor in
figuring out the mechanism so first we
want to think about is this primary
secondary or tertiary this is a
secondary bromide so secondary
substrates can undergo sn1 sn2 e1 or e2
reactions under different conditions so
these are the most challenging
substrates to deal with so we need to
look at our structure a little more
carefully and we can see this phenyl
ring here this is actually benzylic so
if this substrate forms a carbo cation
we have extra stabilization by resonance
with the ring so once I notice this is
secondary and benzylic I start thinking
okay ionization might be likely here let
me look at my other determining factors
the solvent is acetic acid this is a
citic
has an O H group this is a polar protic
solvent because of that proton there
these two factors here the substrate and
solvent have me thinking that carbo
cation formation is getting even more
likely the last thing we need to
consider is the nucleophile acetate is a
weak nucleophile if you draw this out
you'll see it has a lot of resonance
stabilization so it doesn't have a lot
of pushing power for an sn2 reaction and
it's not a strong base that'll favour an
e2 elimination so this is telling us
we're going to get carbo cation
formation once the carbo cation forms
it's going to be trigonal planar and
then we can get attack of our
nucleophile from either face this gives
two of the products now we're forming a
carbo cation at the secondary center
which is a little bit hindered because
of the groups on either side once we
form that carbo cation it's really easy
for acetate to come in and grab the
little proton right nearby so we're
actually going to expect some
elimination product in this reaction as
well the e L keen will be favored and if
you're not sure why go check out my
elimination video ok let's tackle
another problem for the second problem
we're treating this alcohol with
sulfuric acid now I encourage you to
pause the video think about these
factors and see if you can come up with
the answer on your own then you can
unpause me and check your work truly the
only way to learn this is by doing a
bunch of practice problems on your own
don't get dependent on somebody who's
teaching you and be like yeah yeah
practice all the problems you can in
your book practice with me so go ahead
and pause the video now and think about
this problem okay we have an OHA
as our leaving group well this is
actually a poor leaving group however
there's a little more to this problem
than that we have sulfuric acid that's
going to protonate the alcohol once this
protonates the group can leave as water
and that makes it a good leaving group
so we our X
affecting a reaction here okay now to
look at the substrate this alcohol has
one two three groups coming off of the
adjacent carbon it's a tertiary alcohol
well this is good news for us because we
can eliminate one mechanism sn2 cannot
occur with tertiary substrates we can't
get backside attack okay we have
sulfuric acid as our reactant this even
when concentrated as a solution in water
so we do have some water in this
reaction and water is a polar protic
solvent so if your Cassatt is a much
stronger acid than the hydronium ion a
lot of the water is going to be
protonated here so I didn't want to
bring your attention to it to kind of
point you in a little bit of a different
direction
all right the nucleophile that we'd have
here well once we use this proton to
protonate here we're going to have hso4
minus in solution this is super
resonance stabilized a very very weak
nucleophile so we know that we can't
have sn2 reactions here we know we have
water and sulfuric acid which is a polar
protic solvent and promotes the
formation of ions so I'm just showing C+
for carbo cations can form an X minus 4
leaving groups can leave so our polar
protic solvent can stabilize the
formation of both of those our
nucleophile is very weak substitution
really isn't much of a choice here so
we're going to get an elimination
reaction now in order to have e to we
need a strong nucleophile which we don't
have so this reaction is going to
proceed by e1 forming a carbo cation
here
eliminating water and then the conjugate
base of sulfuric acid or maybe some
unprotonated water can come in and
abstract the proton the major product
will be the more substituted alkene and
this results from deprotonation either
here or here so we can get a minor
amount of an elimination product
resulting from deprotonation here and of
sar mechanism was II won let's try
another problem for problems see we're
treating this chloride with sodium azide
in DMF go ahead and pause me and see if
you can figure out the mechanism okay we
have a halogen and it's not fluorine we
have a good leaving group on to our
substrate structure the chlorine is at
the end of the molecule hanging off of
this carbon here this is a primary
halide again this piece of information
gives us a great clue primary carbo
cations are not stable
so this substrate cannot form a carbo
cation this means no sn1 or e1
mechanisms are possible the solvent is
polar a protic often used in sn2 and e2
reactions so now that's the last choice
that we have to make let's look to our
nucleophile n3 - this is a weakly basic
nucleophile all signs point to sn2 here
now I just want to remind you that
primary substrates that are unhindered
just with this long-chain no branching
over here tend to undergo substitution
unless they're treated with a strong
base that is very hindered itself again
you might want to watch my ten minute
summary of substitution elimination for
examples of this on to our next problem
we're going to treat this cyclohexane
with NaOH and heat it pause me and see
what you get again we have a good
leaving group the leaving group is on a
secondary carbon this tells us without
we have all of these mechanisms
available to us so we need to look
further the key factors here really I'm
gonna skip the solvent I haven't written
at the NaOH s in water but the key here
is really the nucleophile NaOH it's one
of our strong bases strong bases like
sodium hydroxide or sodium methoxide
always favored elimination except with
unhindered primary substrates where they
can undergo substitution so this is
going to eliminate
and these strong bases favor the e2
mechanism so this reaction is going to
proceed by e2 but it's not quite that
simple we have a cyclohexane and in an
e2 mechanism the leaving group needs to
be anti-periplanar
to a hydrogen atom if this doesn't make
sense
try my elimination video but if it does
make sense to pause this video and draw
the chair conformation that will lead to
the elimination I'm going to draw in the
hydrogen atoms here and here those are
the ones that could be deprotonated in
the elimination now we might be tempted
to just do our elimination here I mean
if we get a double bond here that's
forming the more substituted alkene
that's zaitsev's rule however things
aren't always as simple as they seem
especially in organic chemistry right
and so let's draw out the chair start by
drawing your two parallel lines draw two
more parallel lines and then connect
them alright in order for the bromine to
be anti-periplanar to anything it needs
to be axial so we're going to choose a
position on the ring where this bromine
can point axial down since it's a dashed
wedge this carbon here has an axial down
position so let's place our bromine here
now let's work our way around the ring
in a clockwise direction we have our
bromine next door we have our carbon
with two hydrogen's don't need to draw
anything there next we have our phenol
pointing up and at this carbon atom we
have an equatorial up position and an
axial down so our phenol will be
equatorial continuing around clockwise
we reach our methyl which is down below
the ring the equatorial position is
below the ring again here and we have an
axial up position just hydrogen atoms
here and then we have our methyl which
is pointing up the up position the
position above the ring on this carbon
is axial alright we might be able to see
this with a little bit of a harder
problem than we thought
we need the
to eliminate from another axial position
and that needs to be a hydrogen however
in this example we have a methyl group
there so this proton is equatorial and
it is not going to be able to be
deprotonated to eliminate this bromine
let's draw out the hydrogen's on this
carbon atom we have an equatorial
hydrogen atom and an axial up hydrogen
this is the hydrogen that's available to
eliminate by e2 and so the product that
we get is the less substituted alkene
now pause me and try this problem we're
gonna treat this tousle eight with n
asme and Osito nitrile as solvent we
have a little D here
this stands for deuterium which is just
heavy hydrogen it's going to behave a
lot like hydrogen so considering that
try this problem and see what you get
okay o tousle is a good leaving group
we're going to have a reaction here now
we have deuterium here but it's heavy
hydrogen it behaves a lot like hydrogen
and so this is essentially a primary o
tousle group here but if you were
looking closely you'll notice this
double bond nearby when this leaves we
can actually form an allylic carbo
cation and I do have a video a little
more advanced dealing with allylic and
benzylic leaving groups and these can
either go sn1 or sn2 so we haven't
really figured this out quite yet we
need to look at the Sullivant now which
is polar a protic those tend to favor
sn2 reactions and we have a weakly basic
nucleophile that confirms it now we're
not able to deprotonate from this sp2
carbon atom here so primary allylic and
primary benzylic substrates can only
undergo substitution so this sn2
reaction will occur giving inversion of
stereochemistry and now it might be
obvious why I made this a deuterium here
we also have a hydrogen atom
this carbon but it made the carbon
chiral so we could see the
stereochemistry in our product from our
sn2 reaction even though it was a
primary allylic example looks like we
have room for one more problem let's go
for it
let's treat this alcohol with
hydrochloric acid in water at first
glance this looks like a poor leaving
group because it would have to leave as
hydroxide however we have acid which
protonates the oxygen here and makes
this into a good leaving group water our
substrate is secondary
so this is our hardest substrate to
figure out because has a lot of
mechanisms available to it usually but
we'll notice that this one is next to
two phenyl rings it's doubly benzylic if
this forms a carbo cation it's going to
be really really stabilized by resonance
our solvent is water which is polar
protic this is also pointing us toward
carbo cation formation and as opposed to
this case up here where we use sulfuric
acid our nucleophile is CL minus and
this is a good nucleophile so here we're
going to get an sn1 reaction now once we
form a carbo cation elimination is
always possible except when it can't
occur and if we look here we think about
a carbo cation here we're surrounded by
sp2 centers we can't deprotonate there
to do an elimination so this
substitution product is the only
possible product I hope you found these
practice problems useful I hope that
seeing my approach will help you to
tackle these when you're taking your
exam or working problems if you learn
something like and subscribe click that
notification bell and we can do more
chemistry together